bella [ __ ] e ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono magari j
ed oggi col mio bel cappello di lana
visto che sta iniziando a far freddo
però io momento anche d'estate perché
sono più sexy siamo tornati su flame
porca eva come si chiama con la minchia
di playing the complex la pronuncia in
inglese e da suicidio e avevo fatto i
primi due finali ne mancano altri tre
quindi l'ex quindi ragazzi devo andare a
sinistra e gli wire remember that ellis
e lo ricorda si chiama elli a perché
l'ho lasciata 18 sono lucente le mentre
si parla non l'abbiano riporta ragazzi
perché uno già una lancio tra tutte le
armi tecnologiche teletrasporti
elicotteri con la cia una lancia
comunque è lì se lo ricorderà i la vedo
brutta prova sprint facciamo lo spirito
dei geyser in mano visto che c'è la
barbetta di agire ma potrete anche
lasciarmi scappare voleva sente dei
bastardi va bene così ormai era arrivata
alla fine è venuto a farmi arrivare ma
siete sheckley amo questo [ __ ]
videogame all'oms offspring facciamo la
chat con rampino poi per bambini in una
prigione che che mira ciao zio
tranquillo il long shot si aggrappa
soltanto agli oggetti di legno
fortunatamente nel peso uno era mica un
po più lontani non ho preso un albero
dietro casa mia
vabbè allora niente lanciano spring e la
molla busi con una molla
perché ciao sono una fa dj piacere
inizio a pensare che questi trampolini
siano un pochettino rumorosi ma guarda
zio si che altro voglio capire da dove
cazzo hai tirato fuori un trampolino di
due metri over jump è l'unica facciamo
power jump
questa non è la rumorosa questa andava
bene mica l'ascensore 17 sì ma non è
mica tanto e 17 piani c'è più o meno
palloncino bottoni o bungee jumping
maggi jumping
da dove l'ha tirata fuori l'accordo
spiega sa già che uno stick men ma io
che sono abbastanza macro se faccio il
bungee jumping succede la stessa cosa
nel dubbio vendono ai pezzi sui veri o
button mi sembra troppo semplice di
palloncino non potevi gonfiarlo prima
devi gonfiando dopo giusto ma serio
voglio tornare indietro col proprio a
schiacciare il bottone voglio capire
cosa fa il bottone fermi tutti
adesso adesso io voglio vedere cosa mi
desse il secchi col botto non voglio
capire voglio capire il senso
eccole dove stava il problema c'è scusa
mi son dovuto catapultare giu perché i
suoi amici da anni
ok non c'era un perché facciamo finta
che inondava ben prima bene come la
prima devo arrivare alla botola facciamo
balance balance già posso fare lo so me
lo sento tipo mirror's edge ma è la
coordinazione nel corpo è sicuramente un
fenomeno bene lo facciamo el youm
colleghi il gonfio la testa e volo
meraviglioso cioè io io io io no io no
come ci entri che c'è la testa piena di
vita ah scusa scusa ragazzi delio c'era
l'allarme di mettervi a chi è che ma
visto che l'allarme di me taglia la uso
la scatola tipo sali snake e alla
scatola e mezzo l'incredibile di
camuffamento c'è una scatola qui cè stè
bucks esatto non c'entra un cazzo
no no sono messi a giocare a carte
ragazzi metal gear uguale c'è una
scatola in mezzo alla merda ma non ne
frega un cazzo la gente almeno non ti
hanno scoperto qualcosa è già qualcosa
dozer cos'è sono diventato un ombra sono
diventati da è così sparisco vabbè vabbè
ottimo costume per halloween amico mi ha
già sei già pronta andava bene allora la
foglia cosa devo parco una foglia
quando sei ok sono vivo sono io che devo
scegliere con cosa scappare con la ss m
sperando che non guidi schettino un
razzo e un motoscafo allora io farei
la ss n a calda quella più grossa che io
ce l'ho più grossa la mia ho ucciso il
capitano me ne sono andato perfetto
vinto ma certi tanit titanic sicurissimo
pensavi che nessuno avrebbe notato la
partenza non pianificata da
effettivamente allora facciamo ora che
tra pietanze su un razzo certo è proprio
il rumore che partiranno
meraviglioso la partenza del secolo
complimento manca solo la zattera ma poi
non mi vedono notizia vabbè forte sega
se la donna non ci siamo ragazzi
stavolta ce l'abbiamo fatta per forza
[Musica]
questa canzone la conosco l'alibi genere
forse l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi però
mancano ancora delle cose tipo anche
quest'anno fatta questa l'ho fatta manca
questa merda si vabbè questo che sta
imitando cloud carro armato devo
decidere dove andare contro quello che
mi piace ap faccia a faccia ce l'ho
fatta assolutamente non era quel carro
armato dal carro armato contro il carro
armato nella neve
questo mi ricorda sempre me tagliati
solo che non era finita così contro
cloud e assolutamente claudio papa in
quanto il tipo di como dove è finita
spada spiega ma è meglio non sapere cosa
è successo ma è un sandwich costume che
bello gli hanno sparato perché stava
scappando il pupazzo di neve cioè i
pupazzi di neve non possono scappare
perché se non gli sparano giustamente
quindi allora andiamo col traffico
incoming
invitiamo tutti
violo no dopo dio merda merda merda
merda e va bene ciao barbara io sono
tempi di reazione di un maurizio
costanzo era un paracadute non è stata
una grandinata grande è uno giudici ci
siamo ragazzi ci siamo un pene non la
posso ancora salvarmi posso che a
salvarmi posso ancora salvarmi presto
airbag airbag work star che non sono a
la stella di sormani ott io sono tornato
nella prigione questa lei scrive the
prison s'arrende mi arrendo tecnico ma i
nomi possa rendere meno che non spunti
qualcosa alla fine sono vivo suo vivo
come faccio a caso aveva complimenti
quindi dovevamo semplicemente aspettare
di dovevo aspettare che vi buttasse
giocatore va adesso mi metto in carcere
thanks for klein uno zio
sto partendo con l'aereo ragazzi è stata
la cosa più bella della vita però manca
questo tipo ma se si è scelto tipo il
berretto cioè non avverrà
ancora lui è che il sacco di infiltrati
in dieci è riuscito è la madonna
montegrosso sto coso la ship nessuno
l'ha notata per carità di dio undercover
agent quindi devo fare la gente sotto
coperta drill pod assoluti a salvarvi
proprio dietro grandi ragazzi
dove vado a vado sopra ma niente ma
niente magnete colma niente certo questo
gioco conosce la fisica è un sacco di
altre cose si ride si creino le comari
perché ragazzi ci arrivo grande zio
sull'occhio e mi vuole lasciar cadere
veramente no non è possibile
bastardo no ci credo mai non ci credo
dai non è possibile che veramente ma è
finito veramente così lurido pezzente ed
è concluso a jersey come cazzo se ogni
volta mi dimentico il nome fini in the
complex ma non impossibile secondo me è
il più figo di tutti di tutti tutti
quelli che hanno fatto fino adesso è il
più bello quindi ragazzi spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto come se dovete
preciso momento è un mi piace anche la
pace di facebook e condivido tante
scrizione sensi di scrittrici vediamo
passioni e ragazzi